how i run my twitter chats
so every month i create a new twitter
chat with dell
where i'm answering questions from
entrepreneurs we pick a specific topic
it may be
how to find your passion how to stay
motivated how to get your first customer
and you basically have me for an hour on
twitter to
talk about that subject ask me whatever
question you have
help answer questions from other people
and we get so much feedback and comments
on all the twitter chats
that one of the participants who who i
know here in toronto local
and city entrepreneur mark elwood wrote
in to ask me a couple questions about
them so he wrote in to say
hi evan i attended the first bit of your
motivational chat last week
then got onto a business development
call that went right through the chat i
reviewed a few of the tweets afterwards
looked like there were some good
conversations thanks for the inspiring
ideas
his first question was do you have many
of the tweets pre-written
so mark i don't what i do with the
pre-written tweets there's twofold
one are i will invite everybody to the
chat so people who
participated in last month's chat i'll
tweet them in advance usually the day
before and say hey just a reminder
tomorrow we're doing our next chat
i'd love to have you join in on it and
that is a pre-tweet that
it's recorded and set usually to go like
at five minute intervals
during the actual chat there's only one
series of quotes that i have pre-written
and they're from michael dell
i love michael dell man michael dell
such an inspiration to a lot of
entrepreneurs and i'm really fortunate
to work with a company like dell
where they have an inspirational leader
so many of the companies
you have no idea who their leader or
their founder is they don't do a good
job telling their story
but michael dow gets entrepreneurship
and he he started his business
with a thousand dollars and a dream and
he had to tell his parents
i don't want to become a doctor like you
want me to become i want to start my own
business
and and he had to prove them wrong and
so i love his story i love all his
advice
and i will take out a few of his quotes
that i love that i feel motivated
inspired by and schedule those
out throughout the chat usually at five
minute intervals so
the chats from 12 30 to 1 30 it will
should be like 12 35
12 40 12 45 there'll be a new michael
dell quote
that is scheduled out everything else
isn't everything else is crazy
uh by the time i log on to the chat
there's usually already a whole pile of
questions
i'll answer the first one that dell puts
out and then the rest is me
like mad typing away answering questions
and uh and it goes until the hours up
and
and beyond so i wish there may be was a
way to schedule those out but it's fun
having the live interaction and and
that's me that's not my assistant that's
not
anybody on my team when i post from my
twitter account
that's me that's my voice those are my
words and it's all live
and that's what makes the twitter chat
really fun his next question was
do you have some sort of tool that
easily breaks your comments into 140
characters including a hashtag
so for most twitter chats to work they
have some hashtag for us
it's dell smb chat
and so that's included at the end of
every tweet
that gets put up in the chat there's no
tool that i use to break down
uh my thoughts into 140 characters
it's it's practice
you know it's a mindset it's now not
writing for
a blog but writing for twitter it's
something
that you get better at it's a discipline
it's
trying to think in terms of 140
characters
right and most of my tweets are also in
response to other people so i have to
factor in
their handles too so i got the their
handles i have the hashtag and then i
only have
that much space for my thoughts it's
just practicing being more concise
and as i've done more and more on
twitter you get better at it just like
anything else any other skill
you practice getting better at it and
and you will and his last question was
one final thing i only use a regular
twitter home page to follow
conversations
it's not that easy 19 new comments
arrive and you have to scroll down to
see the newest of the bunch
what add-on do you use so i love using a
tool called twitter fall
and why i love it is it'll show you all
the posts that come in with the hashtag
and it will pause as you're going along
and if you're responding to somebody it
pauses and then after you stop
responding the new ones start flowing
and so if you go to twitter fall and you
use whatever hashtag you're trying to
follow along with
it makes it super easy to see the
conversations that are coming in
and respond to people it also is a great
tool for
showing on conferences or big tvs if
you're putting on an event
you can load up twitter fall and put
whatever hashtag and as people respond
it'll show up
on the screen so it's great for display
purposes too
totally free i'm a big fan i have no
involvement in the company other than
being a happy user
the guys at dell use hootsuite and
i use hootsuite too to do the pre-tweets
i use hootsuite on a daily basis to
manage my twitter account and you find
all power twitter users
they're not using the twitter homepage
they're using other tools hootsuite's
one of the most common ones
and you can set up a new list using that
search term
whatever the hashtag is that you're
you're using and it'll show up on there
as you go through
i've been trying to get them to move
towards twitter fall uh
we'll see we'll see what happens but
those are the tools that we use twitter
follow and hootsuite
so thanks mark for the great questions
hopefully that helped for those of you
who are interested in checking out the
twitter chats and being involved i'd
love to have you it's always a fun time
you can check out uh the upcoming chats
at
evancomica.com twitter with the
lowercase
or everything lowercase and i'll see you
in the next chat
believe for those who watching like the
video you can subscribe to the channel
see more videos just like this thank you
so much
i'll see you soon
you